skating criticism of India's governing
bhartiya chanta party ahead of no
confidence vote
I've killed India in Manipur not just
Manipur their politics has murdered
India opposition leader Rahul Gandhi
criticized prime minister Narendra Modi
for not visiting the Northeastern State
which is being played by ethnic violence
for months
it's Gandhi's first speech in Parliament
since he was reinstated as an MP
travel to Manipur in June fighting
between the majority Mayfair and the
minority communities has killed at least
150 people and forced tens of thousands
from their homes
but the opposition didn't stop at
Manipur accusing the government of
inciting communal violence across India
[Applause]
sprinkled kerosene across India you
threw it in Manipur and little mats now
you're doing the same in haryana you
want to set India a light you're killing
Mother India
foreign
India is burning if Manipur is on fire
India is on fire if Manipur is divided
India is divided so today we are not
only talking about Manipur but about
India
the opposition knows the no confidence
vote will fail the BJP and its allies
hold a majority in Parliament
but the motion is forcing the government
to acknowledge the violence in Manipur
and the prime minister is expected to
make a statement we trust the Prime
Minister We Trust in his leadership I
hope that he will do it do something so
that you know definitely he will inspect
the confidence and the trust of the
people which is most important
[Music]
Modi has addressed the crisis only once
after a video showing two women being
paraded naked by a mob went viral and
sparked Global outrage home minister
Amritsar visited in May and held talks
with Community leaders but nothing has
changed
there's a lot of disillusionment with uh
nine and nine and a half years of the
Modi government there's economic
distress there's social conflict mostly
social and religious conflict
um so there's it's it's a society in
disarray the BJP has lost crucial State
elections in recent months a possible
indicator of voter sentiment ahead of
national elections next year
foreign